[Musique]
regardez bien cette
photo vous connaissez cette femme oui je
la
connais vous l'avez vu quand la dernière
fois
elle sortait de la pièce en emportant
mon
bébé il y a 30 ans le couvent nous a
volé nos enfants des centaines de
bébés je t'écoute- c'est
passé le
père il a d êre frappé avec un objet
contondant
elle ma pas sa
tête j'ai entendu parler de vos crises
de somnambulisme ce que vous faites
peut-être
violent je crois pas que ce soit
vosignons c'est moi qui pose les
questions
ici
ma fille est toujours
vivante il faut que je la
trouve l à tout cette
histoire c'est grave pardon
jus je
prof je
fille
je pense qu'on ne pouvait pas se
représenter de tels actes de cruauté
dans notre
pays